ken griffin yesterday had some choice
comments
he called the crypto mania a jihadist
call against the dollar
okay he's a hedge fund billionaire he's
criticized the amount of time and energy
spent on cryptocurrencies saying it's
the jihadist call that some people don't
believe in the dollar he's the founder
and chief executive officer and the
co-chief investment officer of
citadel
and here's the quote he said i wish all
this passion and energy that went into
crypto was directed toward making the
united states stronger what a crazy
concept this is that we as a country
embrace so many bright young talented
people to come up with a replacement for
our reserve currency
now this is really interesting
because ken griffin doesn't believe in
the dollar either
ken griffin actively moves billions of
dollars out of dollars
as fast as he can ken griffin's cash
position
is small on a percentage basis
if ken griffin is so patriotic and
believes in the dollar why doesn't he
have 100 of his wealth in dollars
why is he buying hundreds of millions of
dollars of real estate every year
he's abandoning the dollar
he's actively working to get out of the
dollar and get into other assets
it's because if ken griffin like the
rest of us held dollars he would be
losing purchasing power he understands
better than anyone you have to get out
of cash and get into investments
those investments have all sorts of
different
criteria different pros and cons some of
them are illiquid some of them are
liquid some of them are hard assets some
of them aren't some of them have cash
flows some of them don't
but ken griffin's in the business of not
only taking his own dollars and
converting them into other assets but
then he goes and he asks other people
other people give him dollars and he
converts them into other assets that is
the entire business is to convert
dollars and do other assets
it doesn't make him unpatriotic in fact
i think he's a super patriotic guy i
think he really believes in america i
think he believes in doing good in the
world i think he believes in giving
people jobs and doing the best that he
possibly can from a philanthropic
standpoint etc i think ken griffin is a
stand-up guy
but there's no difference in ken griffin
working to get out of the dollar
than me or anyone else
everyone is trying to get out of the
dollar
38 of the dollars in circulation were
created in the last 18 months
politicians don't hold dollars the
president doesn't hold dollars the hedge
fund billionaires don't hold dollars and
neither does anybody else
55 percent of americans
have actively taken dollars and
converted them into investments
45 percent of americans haven't yet
they're the ones who are being hurt
holding dollars
doesn't make you patriotic
it makes you an idiot because that is
how you actually become worse off this
is a story as old as time it's why your
grandparents or your great grandparents
told
save and buy real estate
buy stocks invest your money don't buy
it on material goods don't spend it on
those material goods
this is exactly how you build a life of
health wealth and financial security
but this idea that this is a jihadist
call against the dollar is exactly wrong
because bitcoin is an american
technology
bitcoin is the most american technology
available today
this is
what the legacy system is missing
an authoritarian centrally planned
communist country like china
has banned it
because they understand what the
technology is
the technology gives individual rights
personal liberties and sell sovereignty
back to individuals it protects their
purchasing power it allows them to know
that they have financial security
bitcoin is an american technology
it embodies every single ethos of our
country
and on top of that not only is it an
asset
that allows people to protect their
purchasing power by owning the asset
but there's also payment rails that
prevent a
resilience to censorship
and prevent having to ask permission of
anyone to use those payment rails
it's the most american payment system in
the world
it's global
there's nobody in charge it's all
democratic
access driven payment systems
anyone in the world regardless of your
race
your wealth your education who you know
where you live what language you speak
what your religion is how you identify
any aspect
of you as a human does not matter if you
have an internet connection you're
invited you can participate in the
system it is the most american payment
system in the world and on top of that
we now have the oil and gas industry the
pinnacle of american capitalism they're
all in on this
we are seeing an immense eruption in
growth of energy producers in the united
states
moving their energy to support the
bitcoin network to secure that network
to participate in the mining programs
that is where america is going
the people at the top haven't yet
realized it but this is the censorship
resistant technology this is what
protects your purchasing power this is
what the american capitalists are going
to do and the winners of the future are
going to be the ones that get on board
the win the losers of the future are the
ones who are going to completely avoid
it
to say that getting out of the dollar
into an investment is a jihadist call
is exactly what a rich person would say
instead i would say we should do the
best we possibly can to not only make
the 55 of people who hold investments
get allocated but on top of that the 45
of americans who have no investments at
all we should work our asses off to
educate them and get them invested as
well
doesn't matter what the asset is that
they buy
we just have to help them get
financially educated so they can
actually get into the market
most portfolios pension plans and large
organizations they still have 35 40
of the investments in negative yielding
real return assets like treachery bonds
is that what we should do should we tell
people to buy assets
that are guaranteed to lose money
that doesn't make a lot of sense
and on top of that when you start to
understand that bitcoin actually is a
boom for the dollar it is not
competitive with the us dollar twitter
just integrated with strike in the
lightning network i can now send dollars
across the lightning network to anyone
in the world instantaneously completely
for free
it completely disrupts all of the legacy
payment systems but i use dollars i send
dollars and the person on the other end
receives dollars
that is the future
it doesn't mean that the dollar is going
to go away in fact what it means is that
the payment rails are going to support
all currencies any currency can be used
i can use dollars i can use euros i can
use yen yuan or i can use bitcoin
but there is a multi-currency world that
is coming
and if you think that simply because now
there is global monetary competition
that's a jihadist call
you might be somebody who doesn't really
understand what's going on here because
this is american technology this is a
technology that brings freedom around
the world
imagine how much pain and suffering is
delivered by dictators and people who
abuse their monetary policy and punish
their citizens push them further and
further into dire financial situations
now
if those people simply buy bitcoin
they're protected
they don't have to worry about is my
government good or bad are they going to
censor me are they going to confiscate
my assets
bitcoin is a freedom technology it's the
most american technology we have
and it's disappointing to see people who
have built a life of wealth off the back
of those american ethos turn and say hey
this doesn't help people
it's probably going to do more for the
world
than all philanthropy combined because
it's going to solve from a first
principle standpoint
stanley druckenmiller another wall
street
peer to ken griffin somebody that ken
griffin probably respects and stanley
definitely respects ken griffin as well
stanley druckenmiller has clearly stated
that the federal reserve and the
monetary policy is the number one
contributor to wealth and equality in
the world bitcoin fixes that
and so to say that the same thing that's
going to fix the wealth inequality gap
is a jihadist call makes zero sense to
me
what do you think john
you need opportunity money but cash is
trash you do not want to hold cash in my
mind your money is getting devalued at
five six percent a year right now
through inflation um and look if you
live in america you can participate in
the kind of capitalism structure we have
set up today if you live anywhere in the
world
with access to the internet you can
participate in the bitcoin
environment and kind of structure that
is established today um i don't really
see this being against the dollar the
only kind of argument i could see is
that it could draw away gdp from our
country all right um so kind of make us
less of an economic power but other than
that i don't see this being a big issue
at all and i don't even really see that
being an issue so so griffin said uh to
bloomberg the quote was that what a
crazy concept it is that we as a country
embrace so many young or bright young
talented people to come up with a
replacement for our reserve currency yes
that's exactly what we should do yes why
wouldn't we embrace that if we don't do
it someone else is going to do it yes
that's exactly what we should do so i
think his frustration is around the
attention that it's obviously gotten and
the amount in the quality of people that
are working on it but to your point yet
look he doesn't i don't think believe in
the kool-aid that he's drinking himself
right like i was just looking it up uh
very quickly here the guy has a
portfolio of almost a billion dollars
worth of real estate he owns the most
expensive real estate in in the united
states he bought a townhouse in new york
city for 250 million dollars he has so
much art collects art has so much art
that he loans it out to museums across
the country literally has too much he
said just take it just hold on to it for
me literally so he's obviously uh kind
of not
believing in what he's saying himself
he's out of the dollar himself he
obviously has a bunch of investments
this is another category i think he's
more frustrated uh that the that while
other countries like china and some of
these other places might have said hey
look we're going to protect ourselves
and we're going to protect kind of our
currency and our monetary system the u.s
has has at least to our knowledge so far
embraced it right and said hey look
we're gonna allow people operating this
way uh they've come out and said that
they're not gonna they're not looking to
ban any of this stuff depending on how
it is they're gonna regulate some of it
et cetera but ultimately yeah like we've
been on the uh on the right side so far
of embracing it right and allowing
people to operate in the right capacity
and build companies and attract young
and talented people like he said to
these companies into this network into
this new financial system so i think his
frustration is more about uh similar
with jamie dimon right he lives in the
legacy world right and it's it's about
protecting that status quo and
protecting uh himself and his uh his
wealth and his family and all this kind
of stuff right so i think uh at the end
of the day he's just a little angry uh
we'll call it when it comes to kind of
the success and the relevance that these
new digital assets and this new digital
system has had